[Music]
so tick-tockers in pakistan are facing
charges for starting forest fires as
backdrops for their videos whoa
doing dances or something [ __ ] nick how
do you feel about it i know you love
kickstarter i think
that's uh dedication to the craft
of tick tock that's high production epic
as [ __ ] yeah when you're doing the
[ __ ] the jiggle jiggle song and [ __ ]
and the forces the jiggle jiggle so
that's much more current than the
macbook
you still do it
and away we go i wonder what they were
thinking about like how they gonna turn
those fires off
there's a green screen option on all
these platforms like it doesn't look as
good you don't you don't want you know
it's a green screen you want practical
effects you want visual effects honestly
worth it i am mad at it what makes it
kind of epic well it's in slow-mo too
it's practical
this is my favorite content
i think it's really rude that they don't
put the fire out when they're done it's
like literally well you just did can't
you call someone put it out the wind
will take it out dude it's fine i think
that makes it worse nah the wind like
gets rid of it i think if the fire was
bigger or looked better so you think
it's too small yeah because they only
just little just like one little string
you need it to look like a michael
bailey yeah yeah
like bad boys three she obviously is an
amateur right if she did this full time
it would probably be a bigger fire you
know she's probably like i'm putting
time but not too much time because i
have a normal job do you think she gets
good brand deals from this she has 11.5
million tick tock followers
the fight she's sponsored by the fire
department they're in on it dude
they put out the fires afterwards you
start it we put it out
looks like a shrub fire though did it
destroy the whole area or something um i
i don't think this they don't know if
this particular one did but it's the
thing that's happening a lot i'm sure
she scanned the area to see if there was
people there and then since it was empty
you know she deemed see it's she's not
the problem it's probably the copycats
the people that want to do they always
want to top each other like the ice
bucket challenge so then like now
someone's doing a whole forest and [ __ ]
imagine city challenge let's let the
whole city on fire yeah here's another
one of two guys uh starting a fire whoa
yeah i hate to say it looks freaking
cool oh it doesn't look like it's just
bts yeah
i love behind the scenes stuff yeah and
then they just look at that isn't that
crazy are they just laughing city lights
and that's not even choreography that's
just them so like what what some of the
people in pakistan are trying to um make
happen is that there's places like
australia that suffer from like fire
season like really vicious fires that
got so much land that can get scorched
so they made it like a you're like a i
think when you you're caught with arson
it's like a lifetime prison system
so they're trying to get the same thing
so that before this gets out of control
they're like we need stricter punishment
for this they need to make an example
nah they gave me they gave me good ideas
i think next time i go to barbell i'm
going to set a bench on fire and then
i'll squat
put the plates on fire yeah yeah yeah
that'd be funny
yeah your knee sleeps on fire oh your
new ones can withstand it yeah
[Laughter]
yeah so they um they filed the complaint
the police fought the complaint against
that um girl and then she denied
starting it and said there's no harm in
making videos
the fire was there i just capitalized on
it yeah that's what she said it's a nice
dress remember those [ __ ] that did
that destroyed our southern california
forest for having like a baby gender
role yeah that's more annoying dude
that's way [ __ ] crazy i still don't
know if it was a boy or girl or when the
getty almost got burned down because
some homeless guy was cooking was that
what happened
didn't uh
just i think last week like in laguna
hills or something a bunch of mansions
got burned yeah this yeah this was this
week yeah i think it just happened
there's a big fire yeah a bunch of
houses got was it another homeless dude
making a hot dog was it a homeless guy
doing a gender reveal
i remember when like the 210 mountains
all caught on fire yeah i'm i was
driving back from simi valley and um
once i got into the middle of those
mountains the fire had just started and
i remember seeing like there was one
fire truck there and they were on that
fire and i was like damn i was like
hopefully it doesn't spread and like an
hour later just the whole [ __ ] place
was on like caught i know i was like
damn it doesn't spit
imagine if that's what the firefighters
do when they go to the fire like damn
hope it doesn't spread
see ya
yeah i was in the azusa mountains
because i would see uh the firefighter
plane
like they would go and i think they go
to what's that lake over there i forgot
in like
san dimas or whatever and they'll pick
up water and they come and the bottom
opens out and you just see like water
yeah it looks dope whenever they do that
though when the fires are so big that
[ __ ] looks like nothing yeah like they
dump the water you're like comma bro how
disheartening is it to like set that all
up fly it's probably like 20 grand for
everything you dump it in nothing
happens like you get steam
it does look so funny it's like when
you're like got a whole pizza and the
guy grinds a tiny bit of pepper and
you're like hello
say say win tell me when shots are crazy
because just like a month ago now when i
was driving back from semi there was
another fire on the side and i had my
windows rolling rolled down and it was
like cold cold and right when i got to
the fire like super hot like i had to
roll up my window and then right when i
passed it it was cold again starting to
sense a theme with you dude
every time you see me
there's fires around yeah that's just
crazy though but then even like the san
gabriel mountains like remember like
five six years ago those are all on fire
because i used to live in temple city
and i remember waking up and my car was
just full of ash yeah that's right oh
yeah oh you turn on the ac and it smells
like a [ __ ] chimney in there did you
guys just play with fire when you were
kids play with fire yeah every day every
day dude i would go my dad's shed and
i'd be like okay what's flammable in
here and i would just grab all kind of
spray paint and i would just like make a
make a little fire pit and i would just
shoot everything in there and just see
what would be flammable and i would like
matches i would do everything i would
try to make i would
but you're just so dumb you don't know
anything right so i'm like oh like gun
powder so oh baby powder same thing so
you like
powder and then you know like the caps
from a cap gun i'm like oh those make
loud noises so i'd get like four of
those put it in there and get like a
shoelace and i tape it and then i would
like light it and like throw it and like
go to the side
powder cloud
smells so good
remember once you guys did you guys ever
figure out how to um modify like piccolo
piece yeah pickles
yeah you smash one end
you ever did that and it becomes a
[ __ ] rocket
yeah all the big kids on our street
would do that like it would just be like
you just see these big kids tie them all
up on like a little like car
isn't that crazy that without internet
that became like a word of mouth thing
to do yeah we should bring that back
that should be the new tick tock
challenge nobody nobody lights up a
regular piccolo peep nobody it has to be
modified yeah you gotta like mess with
it you know what's the coolest thing you
guys remember those uh
that little firework that if you light
it and you throw it it just starts
spinning yeah and then when you throw
that into the pool it keeps going yeah
yeah
yeah on the surface of the water no like
it could be in the water it'll just keep
going until it goes out you're like whoa
so we just keep throwing them in
yeah we keep throwing them in and the
parents come home why does it smell like
gunpowder and you see burn marks on the
side of the pool
no idea mommy
let's go to a local pool and just test
it out we almost set our backyard on
fire when we were kids uh because we
forgot we all forgot our keys to like
get into the house and we used to take
the school bus so we got home and it was
me and my brother michael were just
chilling in the backyard and he really
had to go bathroom number two so he
eventually he just [ __ ] in the grass and
then he was all worried like oh like
mom's gonna get mad
and at the time we had a like a little
thing for a turtle his name was angus
but it was like all this water and for
some reason we had our barbecue there we
thought like oh we can just light the
poo on fire
so then we go and did that but then the
flame started but then immediately
started spreading onto the grass and we
were like oh [ __ ] so we were like using
our hands trying to throw water from the
turtle on the fire
and could save us put it out and then we
ran to got the hose and we sprayed it
out so like it was just [ __ ] and burnt
but it was like a lot of the grass was
burnt did it smell worse after the [ __ ]
burned i don't even remember but i just
remember we were just like [ __ ] like we
probably shouldn't have done that now
they're definitely going to know you
know there's just this huge burn mark
and we got crap and we're getting so
much
do you really have gotten in trouble for
[ __ ] in the yard i don't know why he
was tripping out he's like oh we got to
do something with it what did you guys
do when he was shooting did you block
him or did you just like not because it
was just us too so he was just went over
there and he just looked the other way
like are you done yet let me know when
you're done so it's not gay yeah i still
remember that because we were like
nervous when it started happening oh
[ __ ] and we were right next to the pond
so we were just like this trying to
throw water on it what did you use to
wipe
i don't even remember honestly
yeah have you guys ever had to go in
nature and then like you didn't have
anything to watch oh yes
i did that happened i used a leaf use a
leaf would you use lift god i used my
underwear that i had on i remember it
was it lift god i thought it was life
god oh i've used this lifeguard
[Laughter]
but i was going hiking in arizona and we
had just like a bunch of pizza and wings
the night before and so like after we
were hiking yeah as we were going i told
my homie i was like yo actually let's
turn around real quick we're not that
far in i was like i got a [ __ ] he's like
nah just hold it it'll be cool but it's
like for me when i'm with your body it
makes it like worse right yeah dude yeah
that [ __ ] massages the poop outside like
we were getting a little further in i
was like hey no i gotta i got a [ __ ] and
then they were like no let's just go
let's just go trust me so now we get in
and we're about like
it's only two hour hike you can practice
you can hold it in it takes practice you
could hold it in for quite a while we
were like two miles in and then i was
like yo i got a [ __ ] so i just ran into
the like behind some stuff and i pooed
and i didn't have anything so i had to
take off my underwear and use that did
you guys just
i just left it there and then because we
were going to water holes anyways like
in arizona so then i just kind of got in
and like washed myself off
yeah as your friend is swimming next to
your ass
that's what he gets that [ __ ] jerk
splashable with your feet as he's
following you
you're so silly
you're so silly life of god
[Music]
you